sony sony sony sony sony sais pas si
vous connaissez sony tout le monde
connaît sony qui ne connais pas sony
vous connaissez pas se dit vous
connaissez forcément sony sony le duo
sonny le cinéma sony les consoles sony
les smartphones vous connaissez
peut-être moins les smartphones solide
quoique allez savoir sony et leader dans
beaucoup de domaines et a beaucoup de
mal dans l'univers du smartphone on peut
même dire aujourd'hui que c'est un
outsider c'est une marque qui n'est pas
très coté et qui pourtant pourtant pour
prouver des choses intéressantes mais
j'ai bien l'impression que sony s'y
prend toujours un peu par le mauvais
bout et ce qui fait que leur smartphone
ne rencontre pas le succès espéré et
pourtant derrière vous avez plein de
techno intéressante souvenu d'un expert
au niveau des écrans souhaite à l'expert
au niveau de l'audio sommitale experts
au niveau du gaming son étal experts à
360 degrés pourtant là dessus il n'y
arrive pas et on va essayer de
comprendre pourquoi au travers de ce
sony xperia cinq marques de deuxième
version alors sony je les ai déjà parlé
plein de fois moi j'aime beaucoup je
suis convaincu que convaincu notamment
par dernier casque à réduction de bruit
que sont les soli whv dixème quatre sur
des doubles avec son mix m3 moi
j'utilise le solide w h mais l'excellent
3 je sais les noms sont compliqués à
retenir mais les cases pourtant sont
très cool dans l'univers du gaming avec
la ps 5 et avec les modèles antérieurs
sony est marquée énorme on connaît aussi
et les télés bravia oled moi j'ai une
télé sony et la maison qui marche
extrêmement bien il vraiment de maîtrise
c'est pour ça c'est toujours du mal à
comprendre que lorsque vous arrivez sur
un smartphone et bien ils ont du mal à
mettre tous en bas c'est encore je vous
ai pas parlé de la photo avec les
boîtiers alpha et là vous avez aussi des
trucs qui sont super bien donc pourquoi
est-ce que lorsqu'il s'agit d'intégrer
plein de techno différentes qu'il
maîtrise parfaitement bien dans un petit
10 vagues dans un smartphone ça ne
marche plus
j'ai bien l'impression qu'ils le
prennent du mauvais vous pour illustrer
pour regarder pour essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce qui se passe du côté de chez
sony au niveau des smartphones on va
donc s'appuyer sur ce sony xperia cinq
marques de deuxième génération le
deuxième modèle et on va regarder un peu
la fiche technique on va regarder les
différents aspects on va regarder quels
sont les points forts parce qu'à plein
de points forts dans ce smartphone y en
a énormément aidé ceux qui sont vraiment
super bien on par canal et parti pris on
va les décortiquer ces comprendre tout
ça et puis à la fin je contre eux pour
dire ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire qu'est ce que vous pensez de
solides dans l'univers du smartphone
avez vous déjà eu des smartphones sony
est ce que ce sont des smartphones qui
vous intéresse potentiellement ou alors
est ce que vous dites plutôt je vais
passer mon tour parce que
personnellement la copie elle ne
m'intéresse pas et surtout dites moi
pourquoi dites moi pourquoi vous avez
acheté un smartphone de sony est dit
mais aussi pourquoi vous achèteriez pas
un smartphone de sony ça c'est super
intéressant
[Musique]
ça questionne beaucoup quand même ce
design on voit plein de marques qui se
battent pour faire du bord à bord alors
il ya des gens qui aiment pas les écrans
incurvés y ait des gens qui aiment les
écrans incurvés mais on se bagarre sur
pas grand chose là où je pense que tout
le monde est à peu près d'accord c'est
pour avoir le plus de place faite à
l'écran une part belle faite à l'écran
niveau des smartphones est ici sony un
parti qui est vraiment différent et la
ligue je trouve intéressant parce qu'il
vous dise ok nous ici on n'est pas sûr
du bordel est ce qu'on va garder notre
bord durant on va garder notre bordure
en bas on va venir planqué notre caméra
à l'intérieur on n'est pas sur des
textos de caméras sous l'écran il est
beaucoup trop tôt peut-être auront-ils
plus tard mais il a su vraiment ce côté
là et ça je trouve ça intéressant de
dire ok nous on prend un autre parti
pour toutes les personnes qui ne veulent
pas non plus de ces écrans bord à mort
ou qui ne veulent pas d écran grande
partout qui veulent garder un peu de
bordures et bien pour le coup vous avez
un truc est sympa bon pourquoi pas ça
c'est vraiment un parti pris ça peut
être intéressant moi ce que j'aime bien
avec ce smartphone c'est vraiment cette
prise en main je trouve super bien
regardez comme je tiens très très
facilement dans une main surtout il est
pas lourd il s'appelle 163 grammes et ça
c'est très rare aujourd'hui d'avoir un
format qui est vraiment extrêmement long
comme ça qu'on tient très facilement
qu'on ne risque pas d'échapper qui est
assez rassurant pour ça donc ça j'aime
bien et je trouve ça très très cool donc
ça j'aime bien c'est le premier point
maintenant il ya un truc assez
intéressant qui est assez bizarre c'est
sur ce côté là vous avez plein de
boutons ça c'est le bouton de volume de
pouvoir venir monter et baisser le son
ici vous avez un bouton pour l'allumer
potable qui fait office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui déverrouille
très facilement ça c'est pratique ça
s'est très très bien mais en plus de ça
en dessous des retrouve un bouton pour
google assistant c'est très étrange vous
appuyez sans faire exprès et bien il va
lancer google assistant je ne sais pas
s'il ya un an réellement avoir un bouton
google assistants et la guerre des
boutons sur un bouton qui me servira
pour faire des photos quand vous avez
déverrouiller votre smartphone et vous
faites un appui long dessus eh bien ça
ouvre l'appareil photo vous appuyer ça
fait une photo moi j'aime bien l'idée
lorsque je tiens comme ça d'abord un
petit bouton pour déclencher clac clac
sa pratique je préfère faire ça moi
plutôt clair ça ça ne correspond au
mieux en tout cas par contre si je passe
de l'autre côté eh ben la shoah mais dès
votre première cherché à jouer un peu
michel me contorsionner à une main alors
que comme ça tout de suite dans le
paraître beaucoup plus évident est ce
que c'est vraiment dérangeant n'ont par
contre le fait que vous en ayez autant
est ce qu'on aura fait un appui long sur
le bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre pour avoir un google
assistance en tête paru plus malin pour
ça vous me direz la limite c'est un
point de détail mais par contre ce qui
est intéressant c'est que malgré tout
bien que le smartphone soit l'ont bien
que ce smartphone soit fin ils se
prennent très bien en main eh bien il a
coûté que quand même un peu old school
on va retrouver cette grande bordure sur
l'eau ces deux grandes bordure sur le
bas alors tous les constructeurs ou tel
choix de réduire ses bords alors on
pourrait se dire c'est bien parce que ça
permet d'avoir une alternative mais en
réalité est ce qu'on est vraiment sur un
design qui est pertinent en 2020 et en
2021 puisqu'ici c'est un smartphone de
2020 bref je sais pas je me pose la
question voyez je suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en banc commentaire à côté de ça
il est bien fini vous avez un corning
gorilla glass 6 à l'avant donc
résistants également inconnu anglaise 6
à l'arrière donc résistants dos en verre
bien dans l'air du temps ça j'aime bien
et surtout vous avez un très très bel
écran l'avant vous avez un écran oled
full hd +
2520 par 1080 pixels format 21/9 c'est
le format cinémascope cinéma wide 6,1
pouces et vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 heures on
pourrait se dire c'est génial j'ai un
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 heures
sauf qu'en réalité bien il faut que vous
veniez vous même l'activé alors ça fait
un point de reproche que je veux leur
faire c'est ici vous êtes dans vos
paramètres vous n'avez que la
possibilité de venir l'activé vous
n'avez pas ce qu'on appelle du 120 hertz
adaptatif le sens inverse à la tati
c'est que lorsque votre smartphone par
exemple n'a pas besoin de son aide eh
bien il va être en 60 hertz lorsqu'il a
besoin 90 hier ses passes en 81 10 rc
lorsqu'il a besoin de 120 hertz et bien
ils passent on sent d'ailleurs si c'est
pas le cas et c'est à dire que lorsque
vous utilisez ici la fréquence
d'actualisation élevé vous passez en
sens inverse et tout temps sans
d'ailleurs c'est là quand vous avez pas
besoin de son aide vous venez consommer
davantage au niveau de la batterie de
votre smartphone où ça se trouve que
c'est un peu dommage d'un point de vue
logiciel il aurait pu aller beaucoup
plus loin c'est le premier reproche que
je vais faire plus le même reproche
c'est sur la balance blanche je trouve
que la balance des blancs elle est pas
extraordinaire je viens à régler
manuellement c'est très froid très froid
moi je la passe à moyens face à beaucoup
mieux alors chaud c'est pas trés trés
beau être réglé par vous-même et moyens
pour moi ça fera le taf par défaut il
est en froid et fois là c'est pas génial
donc ça c'est 1,1 point aussi important
et je trouve qu une fois de plus ça
devient très compliqué dès que vous
arrivez là vous vous dites ou là là mais
j'ai pas touche à tout ça j'ai bien
mélanger la regarde et je peux venir
régler mais rouge mais vers mes bleus je
peux venir régler ici plein de choses
qu'elle que sais je me perds et une fois
de plus que lui ont reproché à sonner
ici c'est de complexifier les choses et
de ne pas rentrer dans un domaine plus
simple plus compréhensible par
l'ensemble des consommateurs est ce qui
reste en tout cas d'être un frein pour
l'achat de ce smartphone côté
performances on est sur un smartphone de
2020 j'ai mis du temps avant de vous le
présenter donc on va pas avoir le
dernier sa dragonne 888 on va avoir un
processeur qui a un an qui était
présenté au mois de décembre
2019 donc on s'attend pas à voir les
performances les plus folles néanmoins
vous êtes quand même soir processeur
très haut de gamme snapdragon 865 marche
très bien qu'ils aient connue reconnue
vous avez 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage extensible jusqu'à 1 tera grâce
à une carte microsd c'est aussi très
très bien vous avez le modem x55 de goal
com vous avez donc de la 5g c'est donc
un smartphone qui est extrêmement actuel
qui ravit qui répondra bien côté
autonomie on va s'appuyer sur une
batterie de 4000 militants père heures
pour trouver un bloc de charge 18 watts
inclus dans la boîte un gros standards
je trouve aussi un petit peu austère sur
la partie logicielle on va en parler si
on est quasiment sûr un androïde purin
on est sur un android disent très simple
pourquoi pas mais une fois de plus et
quelques petites modifications qui ont
été faites par sony et r&d là rien de
très visuel il ya juste du texte avec
des petits chapitrage fait en bleu écrit
tout petit plus petit que les autres
tailles de police on n'y voit rien on
n'y comprend pas grand chose je trouve
ça un peu tristounet après par contre ce
qui est bien c'est que vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo il faut quand même
trouver quelques très belles qualités à
ce smartphone aux points qui est super
bien pour un smartphone qui coûte à la
base à un peu moins de 900 euros bien
vous avez une prise jack c'est très très
très rare qui permettra d'avoir une très
bonne expérience ici vous avez dû à
iraizoz diot très très bien vous avez
également due à un réseau d'eau wireless
vous êtes bien évidemment votre codec ld
assez vous si chez sony d'ubuntu cinq
points vous avez également de la péter x
hd dolby apns par notre expérience au
bout donc la partie audio étaient très
bien soignés parce qu'une fois de plus
sony est très très bon là dessus pour
moi la partie photo chez sony c'est
vraiment un truc qui m'interpelle au
niveau du smartphone ils ont une
expertise de dengue est il à mettre
vraiment en avance sur leur site web
côté marketing pour venir faire la promo
de ce smartphone sony xperia 5 sony
xperia un steria à roanne qui est plus
haut de gamme et ils nous disent vous
allez avoir la y traquer on va venir
traquer vos yeux pour vraiment avoir un
point très très très très précis tueur
c'est vrai que vous avez plein de techno
est ce que j'ai faits reprochés à l'ex
paria want me le reprocher c'est à dire
que vous pouvez tellement faire que ça
devient une vraie usine à gaz je trouve
ça pas simple à utiliser en fait tout ça
pas très intuitif moi par exemple je
suis consommateur lambda qu'est ce que
j'attends de mon smartphone je vais
effectivement qu'il fasse de bonnes
photos mais je veux ce qu'on appelle un
pôle tennis foot je veux smartphone je
le prends je le mets sur la partie photo
je me mets là et tu clak je fais mes
photos ça me suffit je veux pas plus je
veux juste qu'il fasse de belles photos
ou derrière vous avez un algo vous avez
un traitement pour vous et en amont de
très bon capteur mais je veux pas me
prendre la tête ici c'est ce que j ai
reprochée je trouve que déjà à
l'interface avait pas très très simple a
toujours à comprendre vous avez
différents modes c'est pas forcément à
quoi ça correspond ils sont à la fois
très complet mais un fois un peu trop
complet à peu trop compliqué il faudrait
une meilleure intégration logicielle
pour que tout un chacun puisse se dire
je viens d'acheter ce smartphone parce
que la réussite sur le marché des
smartphones c'est sûr de la vente de
masse ici vous êtes sur un produit qui
au final devient extrêmement difficile
donc s'adresse vraiment à une tout
petite cible il est donc évident ici que
sony ne peut pas vendre beaucoup de
smartphones dans le monde entier et ça
peut être regrettable puisque du coup ça
enlève sony comme un concurrent
potentiel pour beaucoup de marques sur
un très gros volumes et sur un marché
qui est de plus en plus concurrentiel et
gaza vient grignoter grignoter grignoter
les parts de marché de sony bien que la
proposition soit différente une vraie
belle valeur et y ait vraiment de très
très belles innovations derrière ça
devient dur pour eux et là où mon
discours et voilà pour la partie photo
il est également pour la partie vidéo
avec leurs applications cinéma pro elle
est super dans l'idée pourquoi pas je
trouve vraiment intéressante vous pouvez
faire plein de choses paramétrer vos
loupes venir changer d'objectif vous
pouvez venir régler vos iso pouvait
venir régler votre obturateur votre
balance des blancs ok mais une fois de
plus un smartphone c'est pas une teigne
shoot on prend on shoote on veut que ce
soit beau on veut pas aller trop loin et
quand on voit ces capable de proposer à
la concurrence en face là dessus pour
moi sony n'est plus vraiment dans la
course vous avez à l'arrière un
triptyque de 12 mégapixels c'est apple
qui nous fait ça aussi 12 12 vous avez
un premier capteur capteur principal 12
mégapixels ouvre à f un point sept si
votre grand temps que vous avez
également en ultra grand-angle 12
mégapixels f 2.2 avec un champ de vision
nous sommes le 4 degrés puis vous avez
un tel objectif de 12 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 avec un zoom optique x 3
et un zoom numérique x 3 alors je me dis
quand je vois ça je comprends pas j'ai
un zoom optique x troyen zoom numérique
x 3 je comprends rien en fait l'idée et
c'est là où la logique de sony peut
paraître un peu bizarre pour le commun
des mortels au niveau du smartphone
c'est à dire que lorsque vous passez sur
votre télé objectif vous êtes sur un
zoom optique x 3 et vous pouvez venir
zoom et un peu plus jusqu'en x 3 donc en
fait vous êtes sur un x 3 qui rajoute du
x 3 quake vous laisse faire les calculs
sont pas ça très intuitif par rapport à
ce qu'on trouve sur l'ensemble du marché
et pour un consommateur qui viendrait
d'une autre marque eh bien c'était
compliqué de venir s'intégrer
directement au fonctionnement de sony
qui lui est propre la partie logicielle
je trouve aussi un petit peu complexe
avec vos modes qui sont là vous dites oh
la la la la qu'est ce que c'est que ça
alors faute au projet appui dessus ça
m'ouvre l'application photo pro et là si
je ne suis pas un peu coutumier du monde
de la photo je suis tout de suite largué
qu'est ce que c'est que tout ça qu'est
ce que je vais en faire une fois de plus
le problème c'est voler sur une solution
qui est je trouve malgré tout un peu
complexe jetons un coup d'oeil sur les
photos sur le capteur principal c'est
quand même plutôt pas mal on va bien
trouver les détails dans le ciel va bien
voir la façade il n'y a pas de zone ne
soit cramer soit trop sombre ça me va
bien d'ex passe sur l'ultra grand temps
que je suis un peu moins fade alors le
général du trades grand temps que sont
quand même en dessous de ce qu'on va
retrouver ce qu'on appelle grand temps
de notre capteur principal on est
différente du colorimétrie sur le
capteur principal on est un peu plus sur
le jaune année sur la façade du bâtiment
deux côtés ça tire un peu plus sur un
côté un peu plus viol id est une vraie
différence on le voit également dans le
ciel on va perdre un peu en précision au
niveau des nuages molvaer un peu plus
loin regarder néanmoins ce joli arc en
ciel derrière sympathique on arrive
ensuite avec notre téléobjectif x 3 le
détail et bien franchement ça marche
bien et puis on va se rapprocher avec un
x 3 dans le x 3 on perd en précision ça
ne paraît pas anormale là-dessus
capteurs pensait pas d'une fois de plus
c'est pas trop mal on continue sans du
très grand temps que ces termes je
connais qualité quand même beaucoup
moins sympa - terrible avec le x 3 bien
par contre il est très bizarre c'est
regarder la l'oiseau dans le ciel il m'a
fait très bizarre je sais pas trop où
est ce que cet oiseau on l'a pas à la
peinture blanche ne se fait pas le
déplacement est ce que c'est le
mouvement je sais pas c'était très
bizarre et une fois de plus quand on va
à nouveau max c'est pas office hymne
capteur principal on pas sur du travail
en tant qu on le voit il ya une perte de
précision malgré tout on vient ensuite
se rapprocher bon sens fonctionne pas
trop trop trop mal capteur principal à
l'ultra grand temps et un peu moins
terrible mais j'apprends que c'est un
peu bourru tvo plus brillé sur le côté
là où du traitement logiciel c'est très
brut et on devrait tous là donc là il ya
un truc qui est très surprenant qui est
très bizarre on est en pleine journée
quand même donc ça c'est extrêmement
bizarre extrêmement bizarre le
traitement là dessus on continue on
vient au mais pourquoi pas un petit peu
trop aussi un peu trop une fois de plus
le mode portrait alors le mode portrait
j'ai fait différents tests je vais
trouver que ça rapproche un petit peu il
a un peu de mal à vous voyez ici pour
voir qu'on est sur un instinct dragon
1865 et quand même une bête de
performance il a un petit peu de mal sur
les côtés et on le voit différents
endroits où il faut de plus ça voyez au
niveau du doigt et ça c'est un peu
dommage il aurait fallu avoir un petit
laser en plus pour venir corriger tout
ça je vous ai fait pour quelques photos
cette fois ci avec un contre-jour là ça
marche pas trop mal dès qu'on passe sur
l'ultra grand temps que ça me crame tout
il ya beaucoup plus de difficultés avec
elle la plage dynamique voyez là c'est
quand même dingue c'est csc ouf on va
continuer on va se rapprocher bon voila
il fait le taf à peu près maistre que
c'est quand même plus ternes et puis à
côté un petit peu violacé là alors
apprécier la gestion france avec le
soleil en face qui vient un petit peu
modifier ça et puis ensuite dès qu'on
vient donner beaucoup trop bon voilà on
perd en qualité et ce n'est pas
surprenant caméra de self il prive dans
l'intérieur et bien écoutez il a du mal
il ya un peu de lumière mais pas trop il
ya du mal vient de glisser un peu tout
ça et on vend une espèce de lézard
artificiel pour dire supprimer le bruit
des que ceux à l'extérieur c'est pas mal
sans être extraordinaire on voit
notamment derrière ici vous avez
beaucoup de bruit en arrière-plan sur la
plante on se fait un petit essai
d'enregistrement comme ça alors je passe
pas par l'application cinéma pro parce
que j'estime qu'elle est très complexe
aujourd'hui pour le commun des mortels
et que c'est pas forcément ce que vont
venir chercher les gens là dessus donc
on s'était un peu mode poutine shoot on
vient on fine comme ça on regarde un peu
la stabilité est ce que ça marche est ce
que c'est beau sympathique et pas très
beau aujourd'hui là il fait beau ben il
fait pas beau voyez ces voix là c'est
magique et un petit tour sur la caméra
de celle fille ça dit quoi dites moi
surtout vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire comment vous trouvez
la qualité de la vidéo ce soit sur la
caméra arrière que ce soit sur la caméra
cette marque est le membre à côté de ça
il a plein de belles qualités notamment
une certification ip 65 à 68 résistants
à l'eau et à la poussière il a une
double sim est aujourd'hui sony c'est je
crois une des seules marques qui fait ça
vous pouvez enlever votre tiroir de
cartes sim à manu directement double
carte na no 6 ou alors qu'arte nano
signe + carte microsd jusqu'à la
terrasse à jour est déjà dit en plus il
est compatible avec votre manette
dualshock votre manette de playstation
vous le prenez vous lancez votre jeu et
vous jouez avec votre manette dualshock
ça c'est vraiment bien donc on va encore
plus loin dans l'expérience du gaming
vous avez et du wifi 6 du hi hi fi pour
le paiement dématérialisé en face un
smartphone qui est très actuelle la 5g
wifi si c'est un smartphone de fin 2020
donc vous n'êtes pas sur le dernier
processeur mille extrêmement parfois mal
donc sur une très très très belle
machine et qui va avoir du mal à trouver
son public surtout qu'ici c'est un
produit qui coûte de base
899 euros
899 euros et vous pouvez trouver
d'ailleurs autrement un petit peu moins
cher à 799 euros d'ailleurs je vous mets
les liens en bas dans la description si
vous êtes tentés mais est-ce que vous
iriez m vous 800 euros sur ce smartphone
l'a bien qu'il est un très bel écran
bien qu'il soit performant vous avait du
monde beaucoup de monde sur le marché et
là où sony aujourd'hui ce tir a pris une
balle dans le pied c'est qu'ils se
disent on doit être bon partout on doit
être très très bon dans le gaming dans
l'écran dans l'audio on a de l'expertisé
partout on va donc être bon partout donc
ils vont loin partout ils sont pointus
partout mais du coup ça devient une
usine à gaz et ça devient beaucoup trop
compliqué ce qu'il faudrait à mon sens
dites moi si vous êtes d'accord avec moi
ou pas il faudrait qu'ils intègrent leur
savoir-faire dans l'idée du poète et une
chute dans l'idée du smartphone on est
sur un smartphone on n'est pas sûr en
boîtier sony alpha on n'est pas sur un
téléviseur on n'est pas sur une console
on est sur un smartphone il doit y avoir
très peu d'étapes entre le moment où on
prend un moment où de façon très simple
et très basique pas été une chouette une
fois de plus pour les photos pour les
vidéos pour venir jouer à un jeu ça doit
être très simple très ludique pour votre
écran vous devez pas vous embêter avait
rentré dans les réglages pour dire
calibre et on peut le faire quand même
chose mais c'est trop c'est trop
complexe ça doit être simple parent est
le choix qui a été fait pour venir
activé vous même le sens verte vous
n'êtes pas se ressembler à celle appelée
il faut aujourd'hui tout le monde fait
ça à faire ce qui est dingue c'est que
cette marque elle est bonne partout et
là dessus il arrive à avoir un train de
retard voilà tous que c'est dommage
parce que c'est un très joli smartphones
il ya plein de belles choses dedans moi
j'aime beaucoup de formats je trouve
très intéressant mais c'est compliqué de
venir l'ont commandé aujourd'hui en 2021
en 2020 c'était compliqué en 2021 c'est
toujours compliqué on verra ce que sony
nous propose cette année est-ce qu'ils
vont réussir à faire évoluer leur gamme
est ce qu'ils vont aller dans cette idée
de la simplification avec toujours des
technologies encore mieux intégrés à
voir à mon avis c'est une des clés de la
réussite on verra on verra en tout cas
pour l'instant difficile à vous dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas commentaires
beaucoup d'amour des bisous aura ses
équipes de sony et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]